Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui on va parler de la différence qui existe
entre la fusion et la fission nucléaire.
Dans cette vidéo je ne vais pas du tout aborder
la question de la différence d'impact
technologique, environnementale ou économique.
Je voudrais juste me concentrer sur la différence
de phénomènes physiques qu'il y a entre les deux.
Parce qu'il y a quand même un truc
paradoxal dans cette histoire.
Je peux produire de l'énergie en
prenant deux atomes et en les fusionnant,
mais si je peux produire aussi de l'énergie
en prenant un atome et en le fissionnant,
pourquoi je ne fais pas l'un puis l'autre alternativement ?
Je fusionne, je fissionne, je fusionne, je fissionne etc...
Et puis comme ça on produirait de l'énergie gratuite,
illimitée et sans consommer une seule ressource.
Et puis on pourra faire du mouvement
perpétuel aussi tant qu'on y est.
Évidemment tout ça, ça ne marche pas et
on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi.
La première chose qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que quand on parle de produire de l'énergie,
en fait c'est un terme incorrect.
On ne produit pas de l'énergie, on l'extrait.
Pour comprendre ça on peut prendre
l'exemple d'une centrale hydroélectrique
qui serait située au niveau d'un barrage
l'eau s'écoule du haut vers le bas
et on en profite pour faire tourner
une turbine et produire de l'électricité
et en faisant ça on n'a pas produit de
l'énergie on a juste récupéré, extrait
l'énergie qui était contenu dans l'eau
du fait de sa position élevée.
C'est ce qui s'appelle l'énergie
potentielle de pesanteur.
L'eau est passée d'un état d'énergie élevé
à un état d'énergie plus faible,
et nous on a récupéré la différence,
du moins une partie de la différence.
Dans une combustion il se passe
exactement la même chose.
Si vous prenez du gaz par exemple du méthane,
et que vous le faites brûler.
Vous avez une réaction chimique qui transforme
les molécules de gaz en eau et en gaz carbonique.
Et l'énergie chimique dans la molécule
de méthane est plus élevée
que celle qui est contenue dans l'eau et le CO2.
Donc on a pu extraire la différence
sous forme de chaleur.
En bref, produire de l'énergie c'est prendre un truc
qui est dans un état d'énergie élevée,
et le mettre dans un état d'énergie
plus faible en récupérant la différence.
Maintenant qu'on a compris ça on peut
regarder le cas de la fission nucléaire.
Pour faire de la fission il vous faut un
gros atome que vous allez casser en deux.
Petit rappel avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet,
un atome ce sont des électrons
qui tournent autour d'un noyau.
Les électrons aujourd'hui
on va un peu les oublier.
Le noyau, lui, est fait
de protons et de neutrons.
Le nombre de protons détermine la
nature de l'atome, c'est à dire son nom
et sa position dans le tableau de Mendeleïev.
Par exemple un noyau avec 12 protons,
c'est du magnésium.
Les neutrons, en général, il y en a à peu près
autant que de protons voir un chouïa plus
Et si on fait la somme protons, plus neutrons,
on a la masse atomique du noyau
qui est le numéro qu'on place
après le nom de l'atome.
Par exemple 12 protons et 12 neutrons
c'est du magnésium 24.
Et en général il existe plusieurs
variantes pour chaque atome.
Par exemple on trouve aussi du magnésium 25,
12 protons et 13 neutrons et du magnésium 26,
12 protons, 14 neutrons.
Voilà pour la manière dont
on nomme les noyaux.
Maintenant revenons à la fission.
On a dit qu'il nous fallait un gros atome.
Par exemple un atome d'uranium 235,
on peut le casser pour obtenir
un atome de baryum et un atome de krypton.
La raison qui fait que ça produit de
l'énergie
c'est que l'énergie contenue dans le
noyau d'uranium elle est plus élevée
que celle contenue dans les noyaux de
baryum et de krypton pris ensemble.
Et à cause de cette différence d'énergie
la réaction de fission produit de la chaleur.
Qu'on peut récupérer par exemple
pour faire de l'électricité.
Je vous ai donné l'exemple de la
fission de l'uranium en baryum et krypton,
mais des réactions de fission pour l'uranium 235
en fait il y en a plein d'autres et elles se
produisent toutes à des degrés divers.
Mais un point important qu'il faut avoir
en tête, c'est que ces réactions de fission
ne se produisent pas toute seules.
Il faut provoquer la fission
en faisant absorber à l'atome d'uranium un neutron.
Et le truc qui fait que ça marche,
c'est que la fission elle va aussi
émettre des neutrons. Elle va en émettre 3
qui vont pouvoir à leur tour aller taper
d'autres noyaux et provoquer d'autres fissions
et ainsi de suite.
Et c'est ça qui provoque le phénomène
de réaction en chaîne.
Si ces neutrons n'étaient pas émis,
la réaction ne pourrait pas s'auto-entretenir.
On voit donc que pour avoir
une réaction en chaîne et donc pour avoir
la possibilité d'extraire de l'énergie
par fission nucléaire,
la réaction doit avoir des caractéristiques
très particulières,
cette capacité à absorber et émettre des neutrons.
Et il n'y a que très peu de noyau qui ont
les bonnes caractéristiques.
Il n'y a essentiellement que l'uranium 235
et le plutonium 239.
L'uranium 235 on le trouve à l'état naturel
mais seulement en très petite quantité.
La majorité de l'uranium naturel est en fait
de l'uranium 238 qui n'a pas les bonnes propriétés.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on est obligé d'avoir
un processus pour centrifuger l'uranium
et enrichir en uranium 235.
Et les centrifugeuses qu'on utilise,
ce sont elles qui sont au coeur de tous
ces débats et toutes ces polémiques
qu'il y a sur le contrôle de la
prolifération nucléaire.
Le plutonium 239 lui n'existe pas du tout à l'état naturel
mais on peut le produire à partir de l'uranium 238
en lui balançant des neutrons.
Donc voilà uranium 235, plutonium 239
ce sont les deux éléments d'ailleurs
qu'on retrouve dans les bombes atomiques.
Il existe un troisième élément moins connu
qu'on peut utiliser pour faire de la fission nucléaire,
c'est l'uranium 233.
L'uranium 233 n'existe pas non plus à l'état naturel
mais on peut le fabriquer artificiellement
en balançant des neutrons sur du thorium 232.
Et ça c'est le principe de la filière
nucléaire dite « au thorium ».
C'est une filière qui n'est pas du tout utilisée
aujourd'hui mais il y a un certain nombre
de personnes qui poussent pour la développer.
Ça c'était pour la fission,
maintenant on va passer à la fusion.
Le principe de la fusion à première
vue c'est l'inverse la fission.
On prend deux atomes, par exemple
d'hydrogène
et on les fusionne pour n'obtenir qu'un
seul par exemple de l'hélium.
Cette réaction pour qu'elle marche il faut passer
par des variantes de l'hydrogène
qu'on appelle le deutérium
qui a un neutron en plus de son proton
et le tritium qui a deux neutrons.
Dans les réacteurs à fusion la réaction
qu'on essaie de faire c'est celle-ci.
Et cette réaction de fusion elle libère de l'énergie
puisque contrairement à ce qu'on avait avec l'uranium,
l'énergie des deux atomes d'hydrogène est
plus élevée que l'énergie de l'atome d'hélium.
Et donc on peut récupérer la différence.
La fusion nucléaire c'est aussi
ce qui permet aux étoiles de briller
même si la chaîne est un petit peu
plus compliquée que ce qu'on avait là.
Comme dans le cas de la fission de l'uranium cette
réaction de fusion ne se produit pas de manière spontanée.
Encore heureux sinon ça voudrait dire que quand
on approche deux atomes d'hydrogène l'un de l'autre,
ils pourraient fusionner et libérer l'énergie.
Non, pour que la réaction de fusion se produise
il faut d'abord l'allumer en injectant de l'énergie.
Ça peut paraître un peu bizarre de dire qu'il faut
injecter l'énergie pour ensuite pouvoir en produire,
mais c'est exactement le principe de la
barrière énergétique.
On va prendre une analogie.
La barrière énergétique c'est exactement
ce qui se passerait avec un barrage hydroélectrique
dont l'eau serait au départ contenue
dans un petit lac encaissé en altitude.
Il faudrait d'abord dépenser un peu
d'énergie pour faire sortir l'eau de la cuvette,
avant de récupérer plus d'énergie que ce qu'on avait
mis au départ grâce à sa descente dans la vallée.
Ce principe c'est aussi celui de l'allumette :
si vous prenez du bois ou bien du gaz naturel
et que vous les mettez en contact avec de l'oxygène
ils ne se mettent pas à brûler spontanément
et pourtant l'énergie de la molécule
de gaz naturel elle est plus élevée
que l'énergie contenue dans les
produits la réaction.
La raison c'est qu'il y a une barrière
énergétique et l'allumette elle sert à ça.
Elle sert à apporter un peu d'énergie
pour passer la barrière énergétique
et ensuite on récupère plus d'énergie
que ce qu'on avait mis au départ avec l'allumette
et la réaction s'auto-entretient.
Le problème c'est que dans le cas
de la fusion nucléaire il faut vraiment
une grosse allumette pour initier la réaction.
Quand on fait une bombe H, qui est une
bombe à fusion nucléaire,
on utilise comme allumette une bombe A
c'est à dire une bombe atomique à fission,
juste comme allumette...
Et dans les étoiles ce qui tient lieu d'allumette c'est le
fait que le nuage d'hydrogène s'effondre sur lui-même,
s'échauffe beaucoup et c'est ça
qui permet d'enclencher la réaction.
Et donc tout le jeu de ceux qui s'efforcent de maîtriser
la fusion nucléaire pour produire de l'énergie avec,
c'est de créer les bonnes conditions
pour pouvoir initier et maintenir la réaction.
Enfin d'une manière différente
que de faire sauter une bombe A,
parce que ça c'est la fusion incontrôlée.
Alors passons maintenant aux côté paradoxal
de l'affaire dont j'ai parlé au début de la vidéo.
Comment ça se fait que quand on prend de l'uranium
il y a plus d'énergie dans un atome que dans deux,
mais avec l'hydrogène et l'hélium il y a
plus d'énergie dans deux atomes que dans un.
En fait la raison c'est que les atomes qui ont
le moins d'énergie, les atomes les plus stables,
ce sont les atomes de taille moyenne.
La courbe que vous voyez ici vous montre
l'énergie moyenne d'un noyau en fonction de sa taille.
Elle est très élevé pour les petits atomes,
elle passe par un minimum autour du fer
et du nickel,
et elle remonte pour les gros atomes.
Cette courbe d'énergie c'est exactement comme
une vallée dans laquelle se baladerait un cours d'eau.
On peut récupérer un peu d'énergie en passant de là à là,
ça c'est la fission,
et on peut récupérer beaucoup
d'énergie en passant de là à là,
et ça c'est la fusion.
Et le fer lui, c'est l'atome le plus stable,
il ne peut ni fusionner ni fissionner.
Cette histoire de barrière énergétique,
elle permet aussi de comprendre
un autre phénomène qui
a l'air relié mais qui est différent,
c'est la radioactivité.
La radioactivité on peut la comparer à la
fission mais c'est une forme de fission
où le noyau ne perdrai qu'un tout petit morceau.
Vous savez que la plupart des atomes peuvent exister
sous diverses formes plus ou moins abondantes.
Par exemple le carbone qui a 6 protons,
il existe le carbone 12 qui en plus a 6 neutrons,
le carbone 13 qui en a 7 et le carbone 14 qui en a 8.
Quand on donne le numéro après le nom d'un élément,
ça désigne la somme protons plus neutrons.
Et bien le carbone 14 peut se transformer en azote 14
en émettant notamment un électron.
Et si cette réaction est possible, c'est parce que
l'énergie contenue dans le carbone 14
est encore une fois supérieure à l'énergie
contenue dans les produits la réaction.
Et comme dans le cas de la fusion la
transformation n'est pas spontanée,
il y a une petite barrière énergétique
à passer pour qu'elle se produise.
Il faudrait que quelque chose
joue le rôle d'une allumette.
En pratique dans la nature
il n'y a pas vraiment d'allumette
qui permet de sauter cette barrière énergétique.
Mais il y a quelque chose à prendre en compte,
c'est l'effet tunnel.
J'en avais parlé dans la vidéo
sur la mécanique quantique.
L'effet tunnel est tel que de temps en temps certaines
particules peuvent sauter des barrières énergétiques.
Un peu comme si un petit tunnel se creusait.
Et c'est ça qui provoque la
désintégration du carbone 14
et des autres éléments radioactifs
mais c'est d'une manière aléatoire.
Et plus la barrière est haute
plus l'effet tunnel est improbable,
et c'est ça qui explique que les éléments
radioactifs ont tous des durées de vie différentes.
Elles sont plus longues quand la barrière et haute
et plus courte quand la barrière qui est faible.
Dans le cas du carbone 14 ce qu'on
appelle la demie-vie, elle est de 5400 ans
et c'est cette caractéristique qui rend le carbone 14
idéal pour faire de la datation d'objets anciens.
Mais bon il a quelques subtilités et il faudra que
j'en parle plus précisément dans une prochaine vidéo.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, si elle vous plu n'hésitez
pas à la partager notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que comme toujours c'est le meilleur moyen
que vous ayez pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne
Vous pouvez suivre l'actualité de la chaîne
sur Facebook et sur Twiiter.
Vous pouvez si vous le souhaitez
me soutenir sur Tipeee,
comme toujours, merci beaucoup
à tous les Tipers qui me soutiennent.
Et puis vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog
qui s'appelle Science Étonnante.
Merci, à bientôt.